you learned about genre in regards to
selling a movie Oh interesting
I you know I spent I went to American
film market this year to you know help
promote cut to the chase and whatnot and
I a lot of interesting things that like
the the genre film you know obviously is
kind of king in that international
market cutting I've always I've always
struggled with because my movies are
romantic comedies romantic comedies tend
not to really translate into
international sales comedy is different
you know I know people who go to
romantic comedies especially foreign
want to see the famous people fall in
love you know and you know my people are
relatively not famous so but yeah that
the horror films and thrillers and crime
are really doing well internationally
you know domestically I feel like it's
really about what the movies what the
response the movie has been like it film
festival isn't what not like a good
movie can get distribution in the States
no matter what genre it is I think but
if you want to make the money back
International is really the goal yeah
I'm wondering when you were at AFM
excuse me what kind of conversations did
you hear sometimes you can pick up
really interesting stuff that you can
relate to yourself right when you're in
a lobby at a reception something
anything that was interesting that kind
of mirrored the sentiment of all the
filmmakers out there I mean there's
plenty thing about AFM is it's not
really for filmmakers at all like there
weren't many there one of the reasons I
wanted to go is because I never spent a
long time there you know and because I'm
also producer and I have a production
company I was interested in in how it
works a little bit more and the most
interesting thing to me is how kind of
antiquated it is like when we talked
last time about six-month world the
business was completely different then
right and like that was four years ago
and now digital has totally you served
all the things we were trying to do then
and it was on the cusp then but like now
it is all about this digital
distribution and the DV companies and
the digital companies have
they're now have a system worked out
where people are getting paid like back
then there was a problem with
distributors actually paying the
filmmakers and now like there's a system
happening again now AFM seems to have
this this old-school you know like
huckster kind I like all right I got a
horror movie over here and I got a
religious movie over here you want to go
pack a gym go get five of these that is
all right and it's all built on these
really old models of like DVD and like
you know here's our territory and I
don't know it's funny I I don't know how
much I learned except for it's just all
a shell and peanuts game it's a shell
peanut butter shell shell game um moving
the things around and like packaging
well I mean that stuff something you
know and and and things have changed
since we last sat down in so many ways
and I know you you did scream both the
six months roll in in LA and in New York
and so is that something that you plan
to do with cuts to chase your you know
yeah a little bit different
cut to the chase is going to open in New
York February 28th and then we start a
run in Shreveport Louisiana on March 3rd
and then we are here in LA for a big
premiere of March 6th so we're really
focusing more on these big one night
premiere things and because we come out
on VOD March 7th so all of this is kind
of working as our marketing wrap around
to aim at March 7th we're six month rule
we did about nine cities across the
country and what I learned from that is
spreading yourself thin like that and
then all you're trying to do is sell a
thousand tickets as opposed to putting
it out into the world you know and doing
one marketing push and getting that one
marketing push to everybody and saying
okay now all of you can watch the movie
I mean it's just there's only so much
effort and money you can spend you know
and it's better to spend the money for
me on like one big marketing push so
everyone knows it's out in the world as
opposed to I'm trying to fill a theater
in Oklahoma City yeah which is something
we did we you know we
go to a city we kind of did this like
kind of like a rock and roll tour you
know where I would go and do a Q&A
afterwards but then it's like I know I
don't know 15 20 people in Oklahoma City
I have to get them to bring their
friends and then we have to advertising
and then and then the theme of the day
what happened you know I made $800 in
Oklahoma City I probably spent at least
that much getting there and marketing it
to what end
you know to me the most important thing
now is telling people that we're in
theaters but then saying get it get it
at home you know what I mean it's a
different way of looking at it but we
have New York in six month rule we did a
full week run in New York and we got
there and I was excited and it was like
gonna be great an opening night packed
everybody I knew in New York all their
friends were there we had this great
party it went amazing the next day it
was a beautiful day outside I think
three people came to the movie exactly
and it's just like I was just spinning
my wheels trying to get people in there
you know and when the point is letting
people in the world buy the movie and
telling them about it you know you got
to get out there and tell them about it
or they don't know what it bends to you
having travels and done the sort of like
you know Blaine Weaver
you know tour was that people got to
meet you and you get and probably built
a good fan base that way you know
absolutely I mean it really is like I
feel like the reason I keep getting to
make movies is because maybe not to
sounds pretentious but it's a brand kind
of thing like it's like I am my movie so
I go and I meet filmmakers and I do the
festival circuit and I build this
community of people who are supportive
or interested or even just know who I am
and and that leads to an audience for
the next film and like I love doing that
I love traveling and you know they're
people that hate hotel life I am NOT
that guy I love going and being there
for the movie and then talking to people
afterwards and getting people's
responses and it's one of my favorite
parts of the whole thing yeah I could
see that being your strong suit as well
and I could see that be why people would
come out I know it is hard to that week
run yeah it is really costly and
very hard to get that first night sure
it's a party but once that first night
is over is the real struggle right so
we're sticking to the just the one night
yeah you know save some money we have
red carpets at both New York and LA we
can do it more if we only have the one
night as opposed to the whole week of
you know like six month rule
I let the distributor at the time talked
me into you know huge ads and New York
Times he's like this is how you open a
movie in New York and I listened and I'm
like all right spent a bunch of money to
get this full-page ad you know for the
weekend and the weekend section and then
on Saturday when it's empty I'm like you
know I could have spent one third of
that money on an ad on indieWIRE you
know that we're in New York just letting
people know and here's the presale lane
to buy the movie I didn't do that I was
following a model from 20 years ago and
that's that's what this movie has been
for me is saying okay we've done the
classic theatrical model what's wrong
with that what do we need to do today
2017 to get this movie in as many homes
as possible going back to what you said
about romantic comedies being tougher to
sell overseas how about cuts the chase
because some of that comedy that may be
lost in the translation of the different
languages well I mean so far so good
like Asia seems to like us so we've sold
a couple of territories and like I think
that this domestic rollout is going to
help that as well but like you know they
like the action they like Lance
Henriksen who plays are our big bad guy
and so the response has been really good
I'm just hoping that we can keep the
momentum going
you